all right everybody we have reached the
end of the hour but i have one more
story that celebrates the 1980s this is
what i'm liking
[Music]
so meet laken
since she was little her family has told
her she looks just like her grandma so
for fun laiken recreated some of her
grandma's old photos complete with
vintage hair and clothing so let's see
the results this is lakin's grandmother
and this is lakin
that's amazing
let's see a side by side
that's amazing and here's another
i mean it's kind of crazy okay let's see
one more
right
it's like uncanny so laken surprised her
grandma with the photos for her 71st
birthday and she loved it obviously we
have laken on the line now who watches
on wbbj tv in jackson tennessee what's
up blaken
so looking at your background i feel
like you're already rather into vintage
oh absolutely my whole existence is
vintage i own my own vintage shop and
make a pottery inspired by vintage so
that's kind of how all this came
together um i knew my grandma's birthday
was coming up and so i called my grandpa
i said you have to send me photos of
grandma from when she was my age i have
the perfect gift idea so he sent me
about a dozen and i'd say the hardest
part about all that was getting the hair
the makeup and then thrifting the
outfits as close as i i could to the
original and then so it took my friend
evelyn and i about five or six hours
through the hair the makeup outfit
changes and editing all of the photos
and the videos to get them just right
oh my god it's such a it's such a rad
gift like what a cool gift idea um your
grandmother's reaction was adorable so
what did she say to you after
she's just so tickled we all are she's
just shocked by the amount of people who
have seen our faces um we cannot believe
all the positive support online these
photos are are more than me just looking
like her but me but her seeing herself
in someone that she loves so deeply and
feeling seen and appreciated and i think
that's exactly what this video uh did
and the support online did for her so
wow
you're
like one of my favorite people i've had
on this show you are so cool and that
was so beautiful what you just said that
was so sweet and sincere thank you so
much laiken for not only sharing this
with us but doing that for your grandma
that's such a cool thing and i love your
vibe i like want to be you laiken okay
i'm liking your posts right now
okay
all right that's not all girl our season
long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to erasable pin of the
kelly clarkson show want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly just like you
ma'am and creating sweetly they're going
to give you a thousand dollars just for
being cool how about that
[Applause]
oh my gosh
thank you so much all right have a good
day
[Music]